MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So again, we have now
all tools in place
to do a next round of
cross-section calculations.
We have seen how to set
up a matrix element.
We have seen how to build spin
average or to treat the spin,
and then specifically
to calculate
spin average amplitudes
using [INAUDIBLE]..
All right, I'm not saying
that this is all easy now,
but you have seen
all necessarily
elements to calculate a
cross-section for QED process.
So let's summarize.
So we have seen that we can set
up some matrix element using
Feynman rules for QED.
We have seen how to set up the
spin average matrix element
squared using the traces.
Now we would have to
evaluate the traces in order
to derive this formula here.
So I'll spare you a precise
discussion of this step here,
but you can actually follow
this quite straightforwardly.
Let me just step back a
little bit before we proceed.
My goal for the class is
not to have you calculate
all kinds of
cross-section processes,
but to understand
how you would do it,
for the purpose of
really understanding
where dependencies come from and
where this kind of calculation
has its limitations.
The first part is
you want to see
what is the dependencies
on the couplings involved.
You see this g
squared, for example.
That's a rather
important effect.
You also want to see, so
Fermi's this golden rule,
how we get actually into the
cross-section from the matrix
element calculation.
So if you ever had to
calculate a matrix element,
am I going to ask you to
do this once, maybe twice,
as part of the homework set.
I encourage you to open
the book, follow the rules,
look up tricks, how
to work with traces.
And then you should get
to a reasonable solution
in a reasonable amount of time.
But here for the purpose
of this discussion,
we want to just have a look
at a few specific cases
where we make assumptions
and simplifications
to the discussion.
So the first one is
called Mott scattering.
So here, again, we are at this
example of a spin-half particle
scattering with a
spin-half particle--
a different spin-half particle,
so an exchange of a photon.
So we used the example of
an electron-muon scattering,
but this muon here could also
be a proton or any other nuclei
we spin off.
The assumption for Mott
scattering we are using
is that the mass of
this particle, the muon,
is much heavier than the
mass of the electron.
And that's true the muon 200
times heavier than an electron.
A proton is even heavier.
Any heavier nuclei of this
feels even heavier than this.
In Mott scattering, we
also make the assumption
that the momenta
involved are lower
than the mass of
the heavy particle
and that the recoil of the
heavy nuclei, or the muon,
can be neglected.
If we do that, we can then write
the differential cross-section
using Fermi's golden rule
as a spin average matrix
element squared divided
by 2 pi M squared.
OK.
If you then use this
kinematic information,
you basically start from
this matrix element here.
And then you use those
vectors, those four vectors,
for your momentum of the
first, second, third,
and fourth particle.
You find that many of the
vectors are simplifying to ME.
So p2 times p3 is ME.
And so are many of the others.
And there is a few
important factors.
For example, p1 minus p3
squared is minus 4p squared sine
squared theta half.
And similarly, p1 times p3.
So you put this all in--
again, starting from
this very formula we
just had discussed before--
and you put all
the simplifications
and you get this matrix
element, which already that
looks much more manageable.
There's an M squared,
there's a p squared,
there's a cosine
squared theta half term,
and some factor which depends
on the moment times the mass.
And if you then add this
to Fermi's golden rule,
you find this equation
for your Mott scattering.
Again, this is the
scattering of two
different spin-half particles
where one is much heavier.
The outgoing momenta are small.
And the recoil of the heavier
particles can be neglected.
So this Mott's
formula describes,
for example, the Coulomb
scattering, so the scattering
this photon on the electric
charge of a nuclei.
And the scattering particle
is not too heavy and not too
energetic, like an electron.
We also assume that everything
involved here is point-like.
We haven't had any discussion
on the charge distribution
of the nuclei or anything.
We assume that this is
a point-like particle.
OK, we can further
discuss now the case
where the initial state
particles are non-relativistic.
So here our momentum
formulas simplify.
This is simply M squared,
p amplitudes is 2ME.
And alpha is q1 times q2.
Those are the electric charges.
And so then our
differential cross-section
further simplifies to
something you've already seen.
The Lorentzian cross-section
is equal to q1 times
q2 divided by 4
times the energy sine
squared theta half squared.
And we have seen that as already
the Rutherford scattering
cross-section when we discussed
cross-section measurements
in a geometrical kind of thing.
So this closes a loop here in
our cross-section discussion
how we can think
about those things.
The Rutherford cross-section
is nothing else
but a big billiard ball being
hit by a small billiard ball
and looking at how the
cross-section differentially
kind of evolves out this setup.
All right, in this sequence
we have a little bit more
of a discussion.
What happens now if we
induce higher-order terms
and how can we think
about those solutions?
And then have two extra
lectures and where
we go back and
discuss spin, and also
how we can actually understand
this in a Lagrangian setup.